say it
go on say it where's everyone going
Bingo nice
hell yeah
all right it's happening so I will play
for an hour now and upload this is my
first hour to YouTube
um and if I continue to play the game
after this I mean I will but if I
continue to capture it I think I'm gonna
put it on my stream vods channel
uh I will stream as much of it as I
possibly can though because it is a
super fun time okay so uh we're gonna
start out very excitingly with looting
everything and every house
for a large windmill there's a path on
the far side of it
windmill
copy that thank God for Google Maps be
careful
thanks
I will not head for the lake I haven't
stolen all of these innocent people's
stuff yet
and the map's gonna tell me oh boy she
read
I wonder if I can't get in there yet
probably
all right all right all right all right
what you got for me oh [__]
I really really would be completely
empty out here damn okay
Jesus
this is such a wild way to start a
morning oh man oh yeah because I have to
say uh for YouTube again okay nothing
yet
um
thank you to Capcom for providing me
with a code so I could play the game
just a day early
got it the chainsaw man is just just a
wild thought it's such a
such an event
just break that for fun
never roll through a window for fun
nice
stairs
I think I already go oh what was that
what what
oh
not that handy
it wouldn't have even really stopped
anyone okay
now I won't answer because there still
could be people here why didn't you go
to bingo dude
the whole town went it's a riot
honey buddy
okay
I know I have to come back here but it's
still okay it's Resident Evil looting is
90 of the experience all right
I don't make the rules I just play by
them
in a dog house
sick
architectural work here Lads nice work
cool that that's there
um
Gap in the wall but I can't do anything
with that just yet
anything else you need to loot I think
that that might pretty much be it I'm
sure I will have forgotten something but
I can always come back here
because we can't even get inside this
house yet
but soon all right you can keep it
oh
a chicken
oh God
also yeah sorry if the game looks washed
out it's just because my monitor is
having a lot of trouble
so I need to be able to see obviously to
be able to play
um but it may look brighter on the
internet
captcha doesn't necessarily reflect what
my actual monitor looks like if that
makes sense
I got stuck in here in the demo in this
little room it was a bad idea
don't think they'll let me in here right
I can't go in yeah
hell yeah give me that good herb oh
you're okay dude
it actually hurt like a lot
like that seems like something that
incapacitate somebody for a while and
he's like you know what actually I'm
fine
walk it off it's like nothing even
happened
Leon's a beast
I did my best
somebody come up there
right now
thank you thank you
isn't it like a still a pretty long time
before we see the first shopkeeper here
though I feel like that's a while away
if my memory serves me
okay
and out we go
there it is
it's why
let's do a little bit of
Inventory management real quick
what is this resources okay
where am I gonna put the egg
um
wash grenade I guess could go here
you've got to go down here
you can go over here
do grenade
grenade
health
and miscellaneous
thank God for this brown chicken egg
I hear somebody
even if there is an auto sort you have
to sort to your own tastes okay
I ain't doing no Auto sword come on now
it's very important
should check what the achievements are I
know this sometimes there's achievements
for not saving a certain amount of times
I never like
go for once like that but uh
unless I'm on a second playthrough I've
been meaning to do some of the
Village runs
where it's like with a certain gun or
under a certain time limit I feel like
the three hour run would be really fun
you're just uh
gotta sit down and do it
it's my lucky day of all damn
we got options
um
anybody got any any of you cows got any
cash on you
any chicken eggs playing around that's
small maple
Mucho Dinero
I think I need to kill them
right like I could just kind of leave
you dude
I have no beef with you
I'm just here to get eggs
recipe before the original Farming
Simulator
I'm pretty sure
is that a gym
that could be nothing
indecision indecision
oh gee Animal Crossing exactly
take you out oh that's the end of my
knife
knife gone officially
I have a fair amount of ammo right now
hello
well she was a waste I should have just
let her continue whatever she was doing
right here
sweeping Maybe
I'm not really sure
she missed the bell for Bingo
can I get up there
no I cannot okay
well
I think I had to go through there and
then like come out a sideway or
something so I thought I had to do at
least
suppose not
yeah yeah it's back here that's right we
have to go through that again
hello there
um all right go through the house
blue request notes you can take on toss
by collecting blue request notes posted
around different areas view the requests
you've taken in the files menu
the love of God will somebody please get
rid of the blue medallions yeah that's
what I thought it's a little
blue Medallion up here let's get rid of
it that's fine
there is like a fair amount of sway
now you're gonna
performing he coming
how did you get that much
uh
he will Speed Demon my man
is he dead
anybody else hear me
what's everybody here
there's another donut sauce lady
oh damn must be I sorry about your
sister
oh wait maybe you went to Bingo and then
came back
as possible too
shooting like right over their shoulders
we'll get there
um okay
I need to get inside this house I don't
remember how to do it but I know that I
need to
through here somebody bust out of it or
something
still locked won't open
it's not up here
I threw a grenade at it last time or
something I really don't remember
maybe I can um kick it
foreign
devastatingly no
I don't remember how to get inside the
house
uh oh through this way
yeah that's right okay
okay oh hello there a trap
it's always so funny that somebody like
put them there when that easily disarmed
like what a useless trap like it even
warns you that it's there by beeping
oh
really just uh not the best design
I'm sure by saying that I've jinxed
myself
okay
up we go
thank you
I'm gonna go to the house
even if I don't have to
dude he's so much kicking so much
kicking okay I'm pretty sure there's
somebody in here
two of them I think
certainly sounds like it
hello
are you okay
oh gosh
dude run run the vibe's bad I didn't
know about that man
oh God
oh no
okay
maybe I shouldn't have
uh hang on now I want to combine
just these two
and now I'm gonna use it
thank you
why does everybody have to have power
weapons you know
he's proper scary the noises are
freaking me out
oh [__]
[Music]
dude I'm so scared of this man
please let that be it he's terrifying
that I hated that a lot no it's too many
of you [__]
no no no no
I just want to lose oh okay cool I just
want to loot stuff nice unite you know
good vibes
just don't mind me everybody everybody
just ignore me please [__]
I could kick it up but I have to shoot
it
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
let me just come grab this real quick
if y'all just come out here
I think he says oh hello cow
okay
run around
just ignore me damn
go go oh [__] I can't [__]
[__] I thought that he would go through
the window
all right
this way
and then
oh did I miss that
oh I just didn't didn't go the right way
at all
I hit me
all right Leon Vibes are bad
uh we could take this maybe I should
just shoot them it's not like I have a
lack right now of ammo
you really need to be worried about we
got 40 you know hey
I need to keep coming that is a problem
oh [__] yeah
got about my sick roundhouse kick
foreign
that was much easier than I thought it
was going to be like a lot easier
okay
um all right back up back up back up uh
uh let's mark these right there might be
five of these in this area
there's got to be one here surely
medallion
again I know I come back here
I've seen the third one but I think they
also might extend into the next area in
the farm as well that's the thing
let's keep it
and then it's this way that I have to go
oh or do I have to go back
go back in here can confirm
yeah the cows are just chilling man they
have no idea what's going on
what a nice existence you know
oh to be a cow
a flagon
I love those
combining Treasures You Can Be You the
treasures you've collected in the key
items and treasures menu some Treasures
can be sold at a higher price by fitting
them with gemstones
you can always redo it I think so why
not
second one as well beautiful
do you have bonus cool
the knife durability is so rough I guess
we'll get upgraded oh no hang on so I
still have this knife the combat knife
is still there so we can repair it for
sure
great news
we just haven't yet
and I like that you can like while
waiting to repair actually get a a
second knife too that's that's also cool
thank you thank you thank you
do I want to go in there I don't think I
can
this isn't that just gonna be the same
one room yeah
oh I have to I have to get back in there
okay I see
they use the wheel somewhere else
and here
somewhere probably
that's not the way that I came
is it here somewhere
here
foreign
this this sound design is very good
another New Zealand streamer no I'm
Australian
uh I'm playing on Xbox series s
okay
through the gate we go oh I have tons of
Headroom let me fix this real quick
let's do it
so many breakable battles everywhere
gotta kick them all man how else could
we get through them
uh physics
okay that was something else here
signpost
like
be this way
again nice observation genius
you're a real smart tap yeah there are
definitely some texture issues the game
is fully installed but I'm seeing that
here too like this this texture looks a
bit off
um
overall I think visually it looks great
I'm happy with the detail but just
just some textures a little bit wonky
all right
oh what's up
that did happen
in the original version as well I
believe
behind me
I keep forgetting that I can also
roundhouse kick I gotta do it more often
okay
I think in the original that's just one
giant boulder if I remember correctly
oh God
Oh I thought I carried it
let's chill
you look like just like donde estas lady
nobody can take a kick sorry shot to the
face like that close come on now
that's gotta be it should I just picked
the crap out of this old lady
the Kick's so good
oh [__] I love it okay
it's real dark in here real dark
hang on I should be looking for more of
the blue
as well isn't that one here I feel like
I feel like there's one in this cave
somewhere
I stopped looking already I again
at least we will go back
I'm already having like one of my
biggest struggles that I have with
Resident Evil is leaving Maps red that's
my bad
because like so obsessed with wanting
every single thing to be blue I only
left one red room by accident in village
very end of the game actually two
one that I got locked out of
y'all already know I'm here don't you
yeah you know
you just bomb your own town you hate me
that much what have I done
I'm just coming to visit
have you seen Eagle baby or whatever
they call it
Alice
oh [__]
thank God for the beeping
damn it
oh I keep thinking that I'm parrying and
I'm apparently not
I got him too
oh he's gonna get back up though isn't
he I think he is
which is the worst I need more health
oh dude it's so creepy that's such good
animation
I did want to see what would happen
oh no how far back am I gonna go
oh no I hadn't even considered how far
back that might take me
okay that's fine
yeah that was that was super creepy
love it
Wild
yeah and the sound design
they're worth saving the knives for
though because like you just oh
missed every shot mate
you know do whatever you want
there we go
oh maybe I didn't miss every shot
because he actually down no he's not
down
right in the arm oh that was a sick
Dodge
oh [__] again almost ran into it thank
you
ah I went too far
I feel like I should just die like maybe
we just take the L on that one
dude you could kill me it's fine let it
happen
I feel like these are much gorier kills
than we've seen before
and the sound design is very good
[Music]
well we got him that time
Leon you all right Bud okay this time we
will
actually break the Trap
watch out so that
could hear it but I can't see it
Leon's a little bit more haste if you
would my guy
[__] God
give me a break just keep panicking oh
[__] let's see hey buddy
down
oh I love that
hello my friend how are you today you
doing good
they're all spread out this time
it's actually a bit tough
stay down Punk
foreign
literally 100 of the time when prompted
oh no he did it oh it's so creepy
oh
so creepy it's so good I love it
damn it
I thought I got you in the head and that
that would prevent you from shooting me
yeah the AI seems to be better than in
the previous two remakes as well
um
they're a little bit less predictable I
think
which is cool
all right now who done did that
seems more tactical than the original I
definitely agree with that yeah
yeah it's uh it wasn't that long ago
that I played
um
this section of the original and this is
definitely requires a little bit more
thought which is nice
but also I'm obviously like
trying to learn it it's probably not an
organic way of playing
next
why are y'all even getting all this
dynamite
successive I've just well no I did Kill
like a lot of your friends just now I
guess that's it's fair actually
I rescind any defenses I was about to
offer myself I have murdered a lot of
your friends just now
like they started it
I don't want to do with me
that's it
okay where is she about that
hello love
it is a bit too washed out I maybe do
need to take the brightness down a tiny
bit
do they explode on her
no I was like oh she drops it that'd be
cool
we're shot in the shoulder
but no
all right I'm gonna turn the brightness
down a tiny a little bit
yeah
it looks good I don't know if I even
changed anything it looks good for my
screen so I guess it's just the way I
gotta
plants because my HDR is messing up I
probably need a new monitor
oh there's so many more of you
still know oh [__] the backtrack [__] I
start right before I stepped in it
it's a damn shame
yeah yeah I heard ya
okay we snipe up here with a pistol
scope it out
hello sir
should you oh that did work
you could shoot the dynamite out of the
hands
it's gonna be locked but we'll make a
note of it
maybe snow it's there
the sound design in this game's so good
it's so creepy all the time
like you always like oh [__] I don't
want to go
don't shoot the lake water I never tried
it should I what happens
okay
nothing
when you're on the ledge like here
it's really pixelated
no on the ledge oh not this Lake
isn't this the only Lake
I don't want to waste all my ammo what
am I shooting
okay
do it one more time and then that's it
not risking it I don't want to waste all
my ammo
not doing it
this is the place well let's go in the
nice bangy house shall we
can you just kick it eventually can you
get through the walk by kicking it up
you can
hello
is anybody home
should be fine
you can hear it but I can't see it
don't get like locked in a closet here
I'm pretty sure that happens
a couple of babes
just hanging out doing hot girl [__]
what's that noise
but I think it's maybe like a like a
children's party like a fun
like a cool fun party or something maybe
it seems like really positive to me
I keep pressing it what too late
it would be a stupid place to die but I
want to practice my Parry nah I mess it
up again
I had it like perfectly in the demo I
guess I just gotta I think I need to do
it slightly earlier
um wow we're so close to death
oh
inventory is a mess
stupid
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do it I'm
gonna spare you all I'll do it when I
finish recording
oh yeah the knife's broken I didn't
consider that the not having a knife or
something being able to Parry of course
wow that makes me never want to use the
knife
I don't know why my head didn't put that
together but you're right that I can't
Parry with my arms
um I need to turn my lights off it's way
too much glare for me to see right now
uh this is the full game sell profit yes
I need to turn the lights off
okay apparently I call it my you I don't
want me to
lights nope all right well I'll just
deal with the glare that's fine
okay
oh cool hey
you doing all right
ah that hurts you know it seem like you
really wanted to talk
I really like him
also very exciting that he seems to live
for longer maybe just
I just really like him as a character I
think it's really fun
right there
oh no
foreign
the typewriter system and the storage
customized case
that's interesting
huh
wow
cool
all right can't play for too much longer
sacrificial lamb
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins now
I feel like if my hair hang on [__]
hang on
a little Yankee got a name I feel like
Leon and I kind of got the same hair
look at it okay
you move I move
let me honest Kennedy
like this before
I guess
you're here looking for him
I love it maybe
young girl
you're missing senorita how did you know
no
see
I heard chatter about moving senorita
moving here
where who knows but later
saw some men dragging someone to the old
church
hanging with you not helpful
all right
foreign
honestly genius
this game's awesome like I'm so happy to
be playing it this game's like I don't
find it um
I guess I do in Parts it's gonna say I
don't find it as scary as the others but
I don't know I haven't played through at
all
um
or as much as one or two
but it's more like action blockbustery
I took my gear
just to rub it in you got [__] all my
dude
they didn't take my sweet Bluetooth
headset though I've located baby eagle
it sounds like she's being kept in some
church great
I heard it from this guy I met
said his name is Luis Sarah
there's something fishy about him
I need you to run a background check
in the meantime
right
probably do for confession anyway
Condor one who is putting these herbs in
these crates okay
Riddle Me That who is it
that's putting the herbs in the crates
somebody has to be sitting there and
doing that I just want to know who it is
did I miss something
or is that just the door
what about this cool boot
hang on maybe it wasn't
there's more of this car at all
right it's so dark you want to turn that
flashlight back on my man
dude don't even talk to me about Dino
Crisis twitch chat I think about dining
crisis all the time
knife attacks you can perform wide
sweeping slash attacks with rt you can
also deliver quick stab attacks with rt
while holding LV
the animation I really really like it
really like the animation
that's my that's my hot take on the
animation is that I really like it
good uh
mocap if that's what it is
red or is it like
I think it's neutral there's nothing to
be had
stealth kills it's interesting that it's
giving me this tutorial now huh
I guess you wouldn't have needed it much
earlier in the game
but then yeah I love the Paris so much
that I almost don't want to do still
kills I don't know I don't know what my
play style is for this particular game
yeah
we'll figure it out I don't know
yet
oh okay I was like what someone noticed
me okay
earlier than you think
that was timed wrong
because there is like a perfect Parry
that was it okay
it's an in between
thanks for the herb old man
don't mind if I kick your crate
what wasn't my stuff right here wasn't
it that that I looked through no
in here
what are you even doing here
what's the purpose of this building
so I keep trying to
um and I suspect it doesn't work
because there was one encounter where it
told me B was a vade I keep trying to
hit B to evade on those thinking it will
work and it never does
um
so I'm guessing the B to evade is only
for certain
uh bosses or certain circumstances where
you're actually prompted to do it uh
rather than for every time
they both
I don't have any idea of the one green
type yeah oh my God I have so many
knives I'm knifed up
I will also say a thing that is a little
bit like disappointingly simple about
the fiery system but it's Resident Evils
about that atmosphere and about
collecting in my opinion
you can actually just repeatedly tap the
parity button you don't have to time it
well so you just tap tap tap tap tap tap
and it'll
it's seemingly more than likely um
trigger at the right time
so it's not super technical
which is a little bit disappointing but
again it's not we're not playing Dark
Souls out here
didn't expect it to to be fair where is
my stuff
did it close already
oh my God I don't even
oh [__] kidding me God damn it
that's so mean
oh man of all places
hell yeah I will dude I love kitchen
knives I've been now a kitchen knife
enthusiast
uh okay
this is a mess
this is so many not there's just a lot
more knives than I had accounted for you
know
my theory this would be ammo what am I
gonna do with all these this these
resources can be combined with gunpowder
to create a variety of ammo do I have
any gunpowder right now I don't do I
do
I do I do I do I do yeah
and it'll stack on itself I thought for
some reason that that was not gunpowder
and I don't know why I thought that but
I did so we'll do that as well
let's do another one
knives can come over here move this here
gotta keep my eggs though you know
make sure we've got those handy never
know when you might need them
technically we can put those over here
too
oh [__]
oh [__] grenade
great it exists it is it is a system
that I have
okay
um okay
hello the Merchant's just out here right
British stranger
so much more detail then I still have
texture problems maybe I should be
playing this particular game on uh
different platforms yeah all right give
me a second man
Pest Control get rid of the rats that
have taken up in the factory we won't we
don't know if they're carrying any
diseases but we'd rather not find out
get rich quick how are the reason
requests coming along did you know that
you can trade the spinals you receive as
a reward for valuable Goods that can't
be bought otherwise we've got loads of
useful items but I recommend recommend
you pick up the treasure map the most
these map details the locations of the
cultures cherished Hidden Treasures took
me in the lads a lot of time to find
them with these Maps handy you'll never
be skinned again it sounds like a slow
I'll never be what what did you call me
uh show you may have to venture into
some dangerous areas to get them but you
can handle that right
I can thanks mate yeah
sick
save game yes
um
we maybe want to move some
can't move knives into storage
it's only for guns
you see everything else is grayed out
you can't even move the eggs
all right noted
okay
well I'll go kill all the rats obviously
um oh
yeah I think you can choose from
multiple weapons here and it stresses me
out because I don't know which one I
should be getting
once you've completed a toss received
from Blue request note you can claim the
reward by talking to the merchant so we
will go kill all the rats
shoot up fix my goddamn Knife Man
bless you
use key items no longer server purpose
can be sold to imagine
hmm
what's that how have we procured these
Curiosities
you don't want to know I don't think I'm
supposed to combine the Velvet with
anything we can sell that
a deal well struck do I want to upgrade
any of these yet
pin can make up for a lack of skew
friend that's expensive
God I'm always so like [__] what do I do
um
I feel like
increasing at my capacity there seems
like a good idea
rate of fire seems like a very good idea
but then every time that I upload
something I'm always sorry upgrade
something I'm always like should I be
upgrading it when I can just have a
different weapon that's going to be just
way better very soon honestly like I
said
the weapon purchasing in this game
stresses me out so we're not going to do
any of it I'm gonna kill the Rats first
as soon as I can see them
and then I will see what he has to say
I don't know how many rats there are but
they do be in here
all right yo man
but but they can just run away like that
no no no dude
you can and I can't step on you no
wait till you come over here again
but yeah
hey
okay there's only three
oh she need more Reps for me
I'm just so bloody dark
right no it was my own shadow not a rat
just my own shadow
I think if I
go any foot hang on what's this oh
locked wrong I go any further down I
don't think it
these are not the rats you're looking
for but let's have a look
can I turn my own flashlight on
what does it only do it when he wants to
I don't think I can
hmm
rats rats rats rats
has anybody seen many rats
nah they're probably only the actual
uh this kind of looks like sore in here
oh thank you krebsies yeah creative
Clash is really coming up soon it's
terrifying
it's like three weeks man
Wild
uh y'all let me know if you see any rats
that's what we're gonna do before we
make a
make a purchasing decision
kill three rats
and he did say they roll in here right
I think they're in requests Pest Control
taken up in the factory yeah
mystify a mile
okay we're at number two
damn
every time
this is where I killed the first one
I'm not gonna be there
beautiful we did it look at this gaming
I sure did
you thank you something new
um
you get some bang for your buck I
guarantee I can make the space surely
but I'd have to sell something else
right so hang on what is this that's a
bolt action rifle I think that's what I
need to buy here
but then I got a
I've got to sell something for it
or just move stuff right I think I could
probably just move stuff around
but I do feel like that's what I should
buy
how much space you need one you need
just a bunch of space in a row
but I really like that system it's cool
that it's telling me that in that way um
not enough space for [__] I need just
like a full
oh maybe I can upgrade my case here hang
on that would oh yeah [__]
I can do both a bit more space now
it's never a big size for you
beautiful try your hand at a new gun
stranger I will thank you
well hang on
just give me auto sort for now so that I
can just buy it
take this as well free of charge hmm
thank you
foreign
I should do that too I suppose yeah
okay
you don't need that
where's her in Tip-Top shape and it's
the tune-ups that I'd really love to do
but I I don't really have the cash for
it now uh I could do reloads
out there you best tune up your kids
durability sounds good
let's do it
don't get yourself killed now
beautiful
all right I have to leave it there
because I now have work
um I'll see if I can play more tonight
I'm not sure if I'll be able to
boxing of course but I will continue to
play and upload
um episodes of Frozen evil 4. I'll
stream it as often as I can I will be at
Pax this weekend so unlikely that I will
be able to until probably Sunday
but thank you all for joining me I'm
Alana I will see you guys next time bye